[Music]
we have talked a lot about horizon zero
dawn let's keep going let's keep going
uh we stopped doing these just like
straight up ask the reviewers like QA
but we figured it was pertinent because
again we've talked about so much but now
the games out came out yesterday just by
the fact that we it's been lauded all
over the place for about two weeks now I
love it
Kelly I love it I can't stop playing it
actually it's really good um Pete you
reviewed it you gave it a 9 out of 10
yeah we have a lot of questions for you
I'm gonna let you kick it off though
what do you love about this game boo
where to begin
I think combat is sort of first and
foremost the the best part about the
game Eloy is super agile right she and
she fights these like monsters that are
really machines that are super fast and
they always sort of have an answer for
everything that you throw at them so
you're constantly juggling this really
diverse set of tools facing off enemies
that have a diverse set of abilities and
trying to sort of just come out on top
but you also have a chance to be
creative with the stuff that you have
and so really like the flow of combat
being able to mix things up and do
things differently and the diversity of
the monsters themselves like as you
explore the map you run into a lot of
crazy variations and you know the combat
is really the thing that drives this
game home but it's also a very beautiful
world and alloys a really great
character like she's she's not perfect
like there's some dialogue that feels a
bit you know like sort of just drummed
up for side quests and stuff like okay
but as a character like she starts off
as someone who doesn't know a lot about
the world but she comes into something
to own something that no one else really
has ownership of or knowledge of and
that sort of propels her down this path
where she begins to just be the only
person who really gets what's going on
in the world and has mastery over at all
so it's a really incredible journey for
that sense and yeah throughout in the
middle is just great combat just driving
you through it we've spoken extensively
about the world itself but it's weird
I'm usually someone who prefers a focus
on gameplay overstory
yeah but when they can mesh that's great
but this is a one of those games or this
world is awesome I mean like they we
talked last week about their unique take
on the post post apocalypse I think
they're calling it what is it about that
blend of nature and technology that
really drives the story and the gameplay
forward you
mmm or does it I guess well it drives it
forward and so much as like no one in
the world understands where this
technology like you know the ruins of
technology around them came from right
so you see stuff that looks familiar to
us you know maybe a little bit more
advanced in today's technology but like
you can't really piece together what
it's for why it's there what happened
and so you do piece that together over
the course of the journey and you begin
to understand sort of how technology and
science can run amok especially in the
hands of men right
not specifically males you know I'm
saying humans and so yeah like and this
is sort of just seeing you know how the
society you know collapsed and how all
this is viewed from a perspective or
people haven't learned the lessons that
they should have learned from this right
and maybe there's some one sort of
stumbling down a similar path that led
to the destruction of the world you know
whatever so it's kind of hard to explain
without spoiling too much but but
certainly a loose connection to the
technology and how she uses that to
essentially piece together what happened
in the world is how those two elements
makes really well because everything is
super wild but you deal with everything
using some form of technology or another
yeah the footage we're watching right
now is a lot of the combat I'm fighting
against humans was the part that I found
pretty boring but us but we did see a
lot of hunting the machines the animals
Kali from your time have you encountered
a lot of different enemies and what do
you think of the combat in this game in
terms of the hunting mechanics um I
really love the combat like Pete said
like the movement
LoZ movement specifically is it feels
natural even though she's like super
agile and super strong I don't feel
overpowered against machines but I also
don't feel like um like you'd think
arrows you're like oh I'm gonna it's
going to take a thousand arrows to
generate machine but you get like really
specific up like weak points that you
can target and I really really like that
as an element of combat is kind of
slowing things down that's actually a
perk you can get
and trying to pimp like you can see
right there pinpointing areas of
weakness and it it I don't know it feels
really good
I like the slow drip of mystery of like
what happened to the world I love stuff
like that in general and for this
because it's so slow and you're doing
other things and you're dealing with
tribal politics and like a lot of the
main quest is dealing with that over
dealing with the technology that you
don't know a lot about and so I think it
all blends together really well I would
agree that the human combat is probably
the weakest but I had a lot of fun
stell Singh my way through like Vantage
camps like I don't hate it it's just the
machines are much more interesting
because they're like behemoths and don't
have to do a face yeah you have to do a
bunch of like rolling and dodging and
setting traps on the fly and so that's
much more exciting but I did like the
stealth element at least of finding
humans what do you think of the actual
like open-world structure as far as the
quests you're doing right because it's
made people in making comparisons to a
Far Cry game where you're like kind of
clearing these outposts and then
unlocking parts the map which unlocks
side quests people are kind of comparing
it to Skyrim but I think that's more the
world itself how does the structure this
game function overall and does it work
well so I mean the things with like
clearing out outposts you don't really
have to do that
they're avoidable yeah I actually chose
to do only the ones that were required
of me and then after I beat the game I
went back I was like well I want to keep
playing so I'll do these now but but
really what drove me through the world
was the idea that okay you can you can
craft a lot of really interesting pieces
of equipment or purchase them and you
need to have a lot of resources to do it
so you know I would find my so and
there's a certain item that you need
very specific items to get so basically
I was driven through the world by
wanting to find the things I need to
attain new technology yeah I did that
too like targeting certain machines
because you need a certain heart to get
a better bow or whatever it is yeah yeah
and fast travel is an option but you
know you also have the ability to hack
robots to sort of ride them through an
environment and that's really fun like
combat on horseback feels great so I
tried not to fast travel too much
through this game but I you know I
tended to avoid the things that were
maybe like these are the missions out in
the world
I actually just
doing this sort of if you can call it
standard fare right like just combat and
gathering like that was good enough for
me and that I think the game did really
well uh psych hell you were oh I was
just going to say I kind of not stumbled
my way through things but I instead of
looking for things to do I would just
kind of happen upon something and it
like I would happen upon abandoned camp
and be like oh there's you know items
here that I need I'm gonna I might as
well take it down like I found it more
natural I didn't have to ever look for
something to do I never wanted for
something to do even when I wasn't busy
with a main quest and I do like I kind
of delaying the main quest because I
just want to keep playing and I even
hunting like flesh-and-blood animals for
things is it's fun like I'm like oh I
need a boar skin so I'm gonna find the
best place to hunt boars like a very
satisfying feeling to drawing your bow
and hitting an animal and just gathering
the thing and keeping going and yeah but
I hate killing fox you need Fox skins
for like carry capacity yeah your
inventory ins and I love foxes and it
was really sad that I had to kill them
because they make those awful noise
especially if you yeah horrible noise
especially if you do concentration so
you slow time down because they kind of
move erratically and I say noise Fox
makes when it dies in real life - yeah
and it's like and I'm like yeah I know
yes I can chose to ignore that thank you
um yeah so I was like oh I'm so sorry
killing machines doesn't have that
effect their machines they no souls
we would probably spend more time
talking about horizon if we hadn't
already for two weeks Pete your review
nan nine out of ten on GameSpot is up on
GameSpot yeah we also have other things
to talk about today which everybody
wants to talk about Zelda we're coming
up in like right now but yeah in the
meantime if you are still interested in
horizon zero dawn it's worth playing I
love it Kali loves it Pete loves it 9
out of 10 games but go read the review
we have a lot of coverage of it a lot of
videos guides if you're just getting
into it if you haven't picked it up yet
it came out yesterday go check it out
game is uh well worth the $60 that's
crazy to think it just came out
yesterday
it's Jerry weird yeah I played it like
an arrow yes
you
[Music]